oh it's getting hot here hey this is
jackson when i'm here with buzzfeed to
go through my first tweets
[Music]
first one let's go jackson when reading
thirst tweets when
when what when i'm here at buzzfeed
jackson wang's back view is making me
drool well i guess uh your drool for the
rest of her life
i want a boyfriend know you want jackson
wayne i'm here i'm available i know
jackson wang has a boyfriend would treat
you like you're some
magnificent endangered species that
needs to be treasured
thank you no thoughts had empty only
jackson wearing dancing in a wet white
t-shirt later down the road at magic man
album the music video probably we're not
expecting a white t-shirt there would be
no t-shirt jackson win is the biggest
tease i'm mad when he is going to sweep
me off my dirty ass
now it's getting out of here
imagine getting married waking up in the
morning with a man in your bed that
ain't jackson wang could never be me is
the air con on is it really look if that
jackson went was hot before obviously
but his new music video has me on my
knees no hesitation i don't know how to
react to that but i love it face card
body card bootie card thick thighs card
vocal cords
talent card you name it he got
everything undefeated thank you
compliment thank you see i'm i'm i'm
looking for something that that goes
beyond extreme and these comments are
just too nice watch stan listen to
jackson wang song music video and good
lord that was hot as [ __ ] thank you
again i'm expecting something more crazy
oh
now i know it gets crazier
down the road oh sh okay wait just watch
jackson wayne's latest music video that
was so
hot choreography was excellent big fan
of the orgy content first of all it's
not orgy concept i mean you can well
everybody has its own opinion jackson
went owns this [ __ ]
i love it i'm sure the best way to eat
chocolate is to have it off jackson
wang's abs um
inspired maybe for the next music video
jackson wing is so god damn thick step
on me you know what i want to meet the
people who wrote these and want to
answer them in front of them
talking to them i'll let jackson went
throw me down the stairs and i'll thank
him for even touching me no come here
i'll hug you jackson wang meaty thighs
can choke me any day every day
first thing i saw on tick tock this
morning was jackson wang and of course
that so horny i'm gonna call out of work
no still go to work but you can meet me
at night i wish i was eating jackson
wang's whole booty hoe right now
yo i literally want to meet them in
person what is going on yo anyways i
didn't say it in a while but jackson
when i'm trying to eat your ass
especially after this album no eat it
before
with all due respect i would drag my
what the hell is vulva oh oh go with all
due respect i would drag my vulva
ellipse across 130 degree concrete right
now for jackson wang to spit in my mouth
baby don't do that i'm done i would love
to meet them in person and hear them
saying this in my face can we do that
can we do that next time for buzzfeed
can we
no yeah bring them in and tell them
exactly what they wrote in my face and
i'll give them a hug it was crazy and uh
thank you buzzfeed for having me my
album is called magic man it's coming
later
in the year and uh my single blow
has been released i hope you like it and
tell me what you think about it
[Music]